Thanks very much for coming.
And I'm so excited that so many of you have the book itself in your hands.
We're ready.
That's a very thrilling for an author to say.
Um,
this is west credit,
long barrow in wheelchair.
It's a chamber too from the Neolithic,
the late Stone Age,
uh,
which makes it about five and a half thousand years old.
And I first visited this site when I was about 18 years old on a university
field trip and we walked up to the site and our chiefs has invited us to explore
it for ourselves.
So I went in and there's a 13 meter long passage into the earthen mound and it's
created from huge saws and boulders.
And as you walk in,
there were two chambers on each side and a fifth chamber at the very end are,
these were chambers that we used for burying men,
women and children from the Neolithic community,
but not in whole pieces of,
not as whole bodies,
but as disarticulated remains.
So there's been a lot of activity been done with the dead bodies before they
even reach the tombs.
They've been laid out or x car native and the bones had been picked clean by
birds,
by animals.
They've flashes rotted away and once the bones are scoured clean,
they've been collected up and placed into the tombs.
And it's thought that in the Neolithic,
the practice symbolizes that you stop being an individual.
If you stopped being Marianne,
you become part of the ancestors.
So walking into the tomb,
I had this knowledge in my mind that this is a tomb of the ancestors.
And admittedly you go in and you have a very visceral,
or I certainly did have had a very visceral response to the place.
You can almost feel the weight of the,
the earth and the stone above you.
It feels colder,
it's darker.
You go in and right at the very back I was looking and
admittedly my,
my first thought was this is a really cool,
spooky old too,
and then realize that I should probably have some slightly more enlightened
intellectual archeological thoughts about the site.
And as I was walking back out,
my tutor said to me,
Oh,
have you noticed,
notice these marks on the stone?
Just by the entrance and there were two parallel grooves in the rock and he
said,
these are created by late Neolithic people,
polishing ceremonial acts heads and the grooves that have been created by the
thousands of repetitions of,
of polishing a heaviest stone against the Sawson.
It's called a Polly Swann and it was used for that purpose before the stone was
brought to west candidate and incorporated into the team.
And this blew my mind to think that I,
I,
I kind of felt that I'd been at the beginning of history for this place,
that the start of the story and then realize that actually no,
there's so many more clues in,
in the very stone,
in the very fabric of the team around me.
I hadn't even noticed those marks on the stone.
And if I hadn't noticed the marks,
I wouldn't have known what they meant and what they represented.
And then back outside the team,
you're faced by this,
an enormous edifice of standing stones laid out at the front.
Some of them were original constructed when the team was first constructed,
about 36003000400 BC.
But some of them were brought much,
much later around 2000 BC when we're now in the bronze age as a ritual closing
up of the monument,
people came back to this side when it was already 1,015 hundred years old.
They wouldn't have known how old it was.
It would have just been there for ever.
And they ritually closed it up.
They filled it with soil,
but they didn't fill it with soil just from the,
from the ditch next to the next to the team.
It appears that they brought soil from different places and so the thought is
that this was a closing up for the whole community in a much broader area,
that people were bringing a bucket of soil to,
to add,
to seal up the ancestors and they put these huge stones as a symbolic and as a
very practical bar to entry.
The reason you can go in now is because it's since been excavated and so you can
wander in and kind of hunker down in one of the little chambers which had these
disarticulated remains.
But the other thing about West candidate is that when you step outside,
you realize just how important it is to understand a monument like this in the
context of the wider landscape.
How does it fit with the natural topography?
What views can you get from when you're approaching it from when you're standing
next to it,
when you walk around it?
How does it relate to the prehistoric Ridgeway and ancient trackway that runs
along the high ground on the other side of the valley or the bottom of the
valley?
There's a swallow head spring,
which is the source of the Kennett River.
Just opposite actually you can see on this,
um,
on this photograph there's Silbury Hill,
which is this huge monument that we'll talk about in a minute.
A huge circular mound on the next rise in the land,
there's a site called Overton down with,
um,
huge timber,
monumental circle structures.
No one's quite sure,
but they think it was possibly a burial site to start off with and then had
other ceremonial functions.
And you only understand west Canada.
When you look at it in its context,
when you look at it within it's place in the landscape.
And I realized,
and I think that was when the seed for this book book was planted,
I realized that if you know just a few of the things to look for,
if you have just some of the clues to spot in the landscape around you,
it starts to reveal a much bigger,
much more interesting story.
And for me that's incredibly exciting and hopefully lots of other people agree
because when you're standing there,
I think a lot of people,
west kind of long barrow is quite famous,
but a lot of people will see the brown sign,
they'll walk up,
they'll,
there's like a little information board with those slightly dodgy illustrations
and they don't really get much beyond that.
You kind of go,
oh,
it's all right and you stand on the top like I do and you take a picture and
then off you go.
But actually if you have just sort of some extra little hints about what to look
for,
boom,
suddenly you've added 6,000 years of history to the landscape.
You're looking at.
And not only that,
you can start to pick out how other people treated with landscape,
how farmers have respected this monument.
It hasn't been plowed out all that time,
partly probably because of the massive stones and they're a bit of a Schlep to
get out of the way.
But nonetheless,
you kind of start to tell the story not only of the origins of a site and a
monument,
but how it's been treated through history.
The book covers loads of stuff.
So I'm going to romp through a few little features and leave the rest for you to
do your own landscape spotting in your own good time.
Okay.
Quick Quiz.
Uh,
but it's not a test.
There's no follow up questions.
Who knows what this,
this cheer Mueller or there's a plural hair tumuli
Latin scholars,
monks g or archeologists and no,
no,
no.
Yeah.
Earth mound,
earth mound.
It's from the Latin to Matt to swell.
So it's a mound in the flesh.
They look like this.
This is bond come down in Dorset and these are round barrows there from the
bronze age.
This is a time when they weren't doing the communal burying of the ancestors
though bearing individuals and normally you have one either buried or cremated
individual at the center of an earthen mound and then they've raised the mound
above them.
Sometimes you get additional cremations and burials kind of shoved into the
sides a bit like a team or a family grave where first of all it's one person's
grave and then you put,
you know,
grandma and Grandpa and when they've popped their clocks.
The thing about the barrows is that you get them in some extraordinary
formations.
This is wind sports stoke in Wilshire,
which is an extraordinary collection of Barrow's.
It's called the Barrow Cemetery.
There's over 30 actually and you can see that there are slightly different
shapes,
slightly different profiles,
and in Britain we have a good menu of Barrows.
You've got a a Bell Barrow,
which is amount with a flatbed on either side,
a berm,
so it kind of has the profile of a bell.
You have a bowl barrow,
which as you'd imagine,
looks like an upturned bowl,
but you also get weird ones like this one,
which is a source of Arrow where you've got an upturned rim,
like a cup of salsa salsa,
but it's slightly depressed or flat in the middle.
Now,
no one's really quite sure they was thought that,
well maybe if you get those slightly depressed or flattish barrows,
but it turns out that it was a barrow.
It's because the earth has been eroded away or plow down or dug out.
But actually this,
the earthwork,
the circular,
um,
edging has been retained,
so perhaps it was always intended to be flat in the middle.
Who knows what else might have been inside that circle of,
uh,
if you see a borough that has some kind of weird divot in the top,
it's probably not originally,
it's probably a sign that it's been excavated probably in antiquity.
There was a real trend.
There was a real hobby for digging into barrows in the 18th and 19th,
and probably early 20th centuries before kind of modern archeology really took
off and people were looking for treasure effectively.
They dug in and they knew from,
from workman and farmers,
you know,
every now and then something weird had pop up or something shiny and golden.
So they dig in because they kind of thought,
well,
there must be burial mounds every now and then they would find gold or something
precious.
But most of the time,
actually what you'll get is a kind of a hastily written line in someone's
journal saying,
Oh,
we got to the middle of the,
and we didn't really find anything.
There's some burnt bone.
And so we threw that away and we carried on looking for the gold.
Oh Hudson hounds.
Because that is for a modern archeologists,
the treasure,
that was the burial.
That's the thing that we can now learn so much from.
So the ones that have strange divots in the top,
they've been excavated and some of the results of those expectations,
some of the fines,
some of the artifacts,
some of the bones will be available to view in local museums or online.
Those that haven't have either been excavated in modern times.
And so the backfilling has been done better.
So you can't actually see this sunken hole in the middle or far more likely
because there's a round barrow in every parish in the country.
There's thousands of them and they're just the ones we know about.
The must be loads that have been lost.
Okay?
Loads of them haven't ever been excavated.
We don't actually know what's under there.
We know what kind of type of monument is,
but we don't know what's under that or who's under there.
So the next time your I'm driving along or going for a walk,
look out for areas of otherwise cultivated land that have been protected.
So you might see a a plowed field,
but then there's a kind of a square of grass with a bit of a mound shape in the
middle.
That's because the round Bairos or scheduled monument and so it can't be plowed.
And so if you see a weird patch of grass in the middle of a field,
you show your landscape spotting air should be picking up,
oh,
what is it?
What could it be?
What can I see?
What sort of profile?
If it's a foot path,
have a walk around.
See if you can see any ditches around it.
Normally there was a ditch that and circled the mound.
Now you might not actually be able to see an actual ditch anymore,
but you might be able to tell in terms of the difference of vegetation because
even though these were created four to three to 4,000 years ago,
there's still differences in the soil structure.
And so different plants will prefer to grow in the ditch soil.
You might get greener grass,
you might get taller grass and you might sometimes feel it a little bit softer
and Wester underfoot
the raw.
However,
as is always the way with landscape spotting loads of red herrings for your
mound hunting.
These anyone know what these are?
[inaudible] not archeological.
They are moraines that a glace your feature.
Uh,
and these are at the top of miles Dale had in the late district,
the effectively created by class year chuntering down a valley and dumping
gravel out of the bottom and then over a thousands or thousands or tens of
thousands of years.
Um,
they've,
they've crossed over,
they've smoothed over.
So if you see this,
you go,
oh,
looks like a Barrow Cemetery.
It's exciting.
It's no,
probably not.
If you're at the bottom of glacial valley,
You also get kind of longish ones,
lateral moraines where the gravel has been dumped out either side or drum lens
as well.
So they look a bit like long barrows.
But again,
if you're in a glacial landscape then be wary.
This is Silbury Hill,
which is opposite west at long Barrow and wheelchair.
If you want a day trip to go and visit some amazing brushy archeology out of
London,
I would say go to wheelchair.
You could even bypass Stonehenge.
Stop and have a quick look to,
but actually goes to west Kenneth Long,
go to Avery,
go to Silvery Hill and you've got a really fantastic world class.
It's so,
but as part of a world heritage site,
and rightly so,
Silbury Hill is the largest manmade mound in Europe.
It's estimated to have taken about 4 million man hours of labor and it comprises
about half a million tons of chalk and soil.
We don't really know why it was constructed.
It was built in about 2,400 BC.
So just at the cusp of the turning point from the,
from the stone age,
the late stagnation,
and they're lytic to the bronze age.
So the introduction of mixed metal working different cultural practices in terms
of the burial,
you've moved away from communal,
you've moved towards individual burial suggests that actually does it.
A different power structure in society that it's not about the ancestors,
it's not about communality.
It's not about shared ownership necessarily.
It might be more about hierarchy and wealth of individuals and strength and
power of individuals.
And when you look at a monument like this,
it's possibly also about mythmaking,
about individuals.
The king from which we are all descended.
The one who was here way before us,
who was my tia,
he was greater.
Who was,
I don't know,
Demi.
God,
we don't know.
We have to fill in the blanks now.
The archeologists,
they don't know.
No.
Only we can only we can gas or what it is.
That's not true.
We can all gas because if you,
you know,
feed yourself with the pieces of information,
filling in the blanks,
making that leap of imagination is something that we're all entitled today.
The weird thing about Silver Hill is that they thought it was,
um,
the,
the kind of the folklore story is that it was king cell with a golden chariot in
the middle.
Um,
auntie's horses and king cell in his golden chariot did not appear when they dug
into the mountain,
they tried to dig in from the top.
They tried to dig in from the side and then in the 1960s,
they tried to dig in from the other side and it was only in 2007 the English
heritage when,
okay,
we think that the,
you know,
it's kind of a bit EDM cheese and though we need to sort this out and fill in
the holes.
Um,
so they excavated and what they discovered was that it's a,
they confirmed his date,
but what they also discovered is that it started off as quite a small mound.
It seems to start us off.
There's like a regular round barrow.
And then went poof,
ran by Ron Steroids.
No one really knows why.
Uh,
and it's,
it's yours to explore and wonder.
Okay,
there are loads of other mounds in Britain.
Britain is full of lumps and bumps.
This is a mot,
uh,
in Oxford.
It's um,
uh,
Norman mot.
So they were raised by the Normans after the 10 66 conquest as a kind of short,
sharp,
we're now in charge.
This was actually built in the middle of the Saxon town,
so people would have been cleared out of their homes and probably enslaved to
provide the labor,
the pure grunt work.
And you'd have a Bailey,
an enclosure around the outsides and then a mot this earthen mound,
nice sharp sides,
flat top,
and you put a wooden structure on top to fit,
very defensible,
not very comfortable.
Um,
and they think probably flat packed.
They think that Norman Norman's were great.
They were very well,
they were great at fighting and invading me can debate the morality.
Um,
but they were really great at,
at kind of doing a kind of big push.
And so what they would do was establish a perimeter,
very much like modern military.
Now establish a perimeter,
defend the perimeter,
and then you can build within,
and this is not just about might,
it's also about defensibility.
And the reason they used flatpack sort of prefab pieces is that they could move
their bits of castle to the next hotspot.
So much like modern military,
you get your kit to their front line,
you establish a perimeter,
you establish your defenses,
and then you can do your,
were patrolling,
policing and um,
smiting from there.
And then,
um,
how many of you have driven up and down the a 40.
Does this look familiar as you're driving out towards the turnoff for Heathrow?
Three four huge hills come into VA that you driving out of London there on the
left,
they're called North Arla fields and they are monumental mounds,
but they weren't constructed in pre history.
They were constructed not that long ago from the remains of the Wembley Stadium
and the foundations of the Westfield shopping center.
As far as we know,
there's no one buried under there.
Okay.
Um,
how many of you go walking ever wandering up hills?
Yeah.
Oh,
Yay.
Um,
you walk to the top of a hill and you see a can amount of stones.
Some of them are navigational cans,
so when you're stopping her standing at the top of stuff,
they'll pike and you know,
you don't know quite which way to go.
And you see a bit of a can through the cloud and the fog in the snow.
In the mist.
Yeah.
You're on the way.
Some of them are walkers cans where they might not actually be that much use
navigationally speaking.
But everyone who's tracks up there sort of sees amount and you can't help.
It's human instinct to pick up a stone and stick one on top.
I've been there too.
But underneath some them are the remains of,
again,
pre historic burial monuments because in the lowland areas where you've got
soil,
people would construct an earthen mound in the upland areas where young goal,
how much soil people would construct the same mound,
the same monument style,
but they'd use stone.
So you get a can of burial can now the thing that you're looking for the next
time you try and look to the top of a hill and you kind of go,
Ooh,
is this a archeological can or just a canny can on an ordinance survey map.
If you see that Gothic type face that Chimi Alice was written in,
then indicates it's an archaeological feature that someone has gone along,
surveyed it and said,
yes,
this is a thing.
It's not just a mound because a farmer wants to put a silo on top or someone was
digging sand and that's the quarrying remains.
If it says it in Gothic type face,
it's archaeological.
If it says to Mueller's,
then you know it's a burial mound.
If it says Ken in Gothic type face,
then you know it's a burial.
Can an archeological ancient can.
It's exciting because sometimes you get really cool little insights.
Sometimes you've got a modern can hiding under a
title in totally,
um,
uh,
hiding what,
what prehistory might be underneath,
but sometimes not.
This is,
um,
ne Fan.
Oh,
I can't ever say Brackney og.
Forgive my pronunciation in the Brecon beacons and actually can see the remains
of what would have probably been a standing shelter of stones.
And in the middle a stone kissed a stone box in which,
um,
cremated remains would have been placed.
So next time you're at a can or a kind of a weird collection of stone somewhere,
look on the ordnance survey map.
If it says that it can is marked,
then you're looking for archaeological evidence.
Look to see if you can see any evidence of curb stones that mark out the
original circle that that encompassed the monument.
Look for anything that's depressed and any stones that are laid down vertically
into the earth because they might be the remains of a Kest.
And if you see big stones like this,
you may be dealing with the remains of what was some kind of chambered monument
that was then covered by earth.
So those documents,
I don't know if you've seen dolmans where you've kind of got like an improbable
capstone balancing on verticals.
They would probably have been mostly covered by earth.
And what remains is the stones.
But some,
I like this,
the earth has gone or the earth probably wasn't ever there because it's upland.
So it would have had a stone capping and larger stones to create some kind of
central box.
But this is what we're,
this is what we're left with.
Okay,
let's talk trees.
Um,
London is really good for ancient trees actually.
You've got high Gatewood in the north,
you've got Epping forest,
absolutely fantastic.
And the woodland trust actually have an ancient tree database with more than
110,000 ancient trees,
which is pretty cool.
If you see any fat old trees that they don't know about,
then tell him cause they want to know about them.
Um,
in ancient woodlands,
however,
what you're looking for is signs of modification.
So in Highgate word and Epping forest,
you're looking for three key ways that the trees have been modified.
The first on the top is a coppice.
Uh,
so you cut a broad leaf tree down low at the base and it encourages it to shoot
new growth.
So from one root base,
you get lots of trunks.
Now what your looking for our trees with sort of a glove,
a fingers of,
of um,
trunks that have all grown up.
Because what we're looking for is a medieval forestry practice that has
effectively been stopped in time.
Ancient woodlands in Britain are officially designated if they've been
permanently wooded from 1,680 in England and Wales and 1750 in Scotland.
That's not because Scottish trees grow incredibly differently.
It's just because of the records that are available.
So they went,
oh well we can't get further back then.
1750 so we'll,
we'll just make our peace with it being ancient if it's,
if it's been there since 1750 but when you're looking at copies trees,
now there are actually modern woodlands,
which are still using these techniques.
They're very good for woodland management,
but when you're looking for ancient woodlands,
you'll,
you'll see kind of big trunks or coming out of one root base.
That's the sign of a capias that has been left to grow out.
It's been neglected.
These ones here.
This is a Paul od ancient woodlands in Medieval Times,
through the Elizabethan times and on up until the modern times,
rarely were very,
very hard working parts of a land management system.
They weren't for walking the dog and you know,
building dams they were for producing valuable timber and firewood and fencing
and food for your animals,
uh,
for digging,
um,
uh,
resources that you'd need at home.
Uh,
so a lot of woodlands were also used for grazing animals on the understory.
So if you had your copies to trees and then you had,
um,
there perhaps coming in or cows,
they would eat all the new sheets and you weren't actually end up with any
timber.
So what people would do was Pollard Pollard.
So you let the tree grow up two to three meters high,
sometimes four meters,
which is quite high.
And then you lop it off and encourage that new growth.
So you get a polo like this,
this is a weird hybrid called a cop hard,
uh,
which is you copy this,
you let it grow up and then you,
Paul odd.
So they call it a cop hard.
What you're looking for,
as I said,
are the fingers of trees.
And you'll probably also see thing fingery trees near to large standard straight
grand trees.
And they called them maidens and Highgate woods.
A fantastic example.
You've got oak standards and you've got horn beam corpuses and they're really
fun to spot.
I went out with my nephew who's five and we wandered around the woodland and we
wandered around looking for three years and for us,
which a cop says and Warner's,
which are oak standards.
And we were talking about what the timber would have been used for in a time
before steel in a time before plastic.
So we worked out and he ran around.
He absolutely loved it.
He ran around the forest looking for three years and for us that were used for
fences and houses.
And he used Warner's,
what are they for ships?
Kings ships,
ships.
One is houses and fences,
three of them for us.
And,
and it was,
he's five and he was doing landscape spotting and then we ran around more and we
found them an earthen bank.
Uh,
would bank,
which would have marked out a distinguished,
uh,
an area of woodland that would have been managed slightly differently to the bit
next door.
Um,
when you're hunting out ancient woodlands,
um,
look also at place names as well.
Um,
Holly trees,
what often used for feeding cattle in hard winters,
so names with Hollins indicates a standard Holly trees that would have been
useful if you're actually looking for ancient trees.
However,
don't look in ancient woodlands because ancient woodlands where so heavily
managed that no one ever let a tree grow to a great age because at a certain
point,
an ancient tree becomes hollow,
it starts to decay,
bits of it starts to fall off,
the canopy starts to retrench and it becomes a fantastic resource for wildlife,
but not that great for timber.
If you're looking for an ancient tree,
look in states,
the kind of larger states,
state,
Holmes,
dear parks,
places that perhaps once would've been wooded pasture,
um,
like bits of apping like Ashra gestate in Hartfordshire,
this magnificent beasts does on authors dike.
So it would have been used as a boundary marker.
Okay.
Uh,
what is the best way to age and ancient tree without chopping it down
and it guesses,
yes.
Girth.
What's the most fun way to measure the girth of a tree?
Hugger it
with oak trees that are free growing free standing so they haven't been copied
or anything like that.
Um,
bearing in mind that your arm span is about the same as your height.
So based on being one half meters tall,
two hugs of an oak tree,
130 years old.
It's not ancient.
Yeah.
Three hugs,
250 years old.
That means that the oak tree is now officially ancient.
There are oak trees in Britain that they think are over a thousand years old,
which is extraordinary and they are monsters,
absolute monsters.
And it's,
it sort of feels like a privilege to be in their presence and think about what
history they've lived through.
But oak trees on the grand scheme of ancient trees are kind of the babies.
They don't really last that long.
All things considered you trees are the granddaddies of the mall.
You trees are the longest living organisms and Europe and incredibly,
this still blows my mind.
Um,
the oldest oak tree,
you trees in Britain and uh,
we've got the oldest,
uh,
you trees in the whole of Europe.
The oldest you trees are between four and 5,000 is old and the three oldest
which are named in the book all in church yards.
Now they obviously massively predates Christianity.
They predate the churchyard,
but there's a very strong connection in Britain with you trees being in church
halls and graveyards.
No one's quite sure why.
There were lots of different theories,
but the,
the most water tight theory is that you trees were considered sacred in some way
by pagan native British religions.
And so when the early Christians turned up in the fourth and fifth centuries,
they appropriated pagan sites because they were pretty clever and went,
okay,
well we'll keep the sacred site,
we'll just change the gods.
And you trees came with the,
came with the landscape and you trees are actually fantastic in terms of the
symbolism.
It fits really well with Christianity because when you cut them,
the SAP that comes out is red.
It looks like they're bleeding red,
they're evergreen.
So you can link it into notions of everlasting life.
They've got red berries,
which medieval people would link to the drops of blood that Christ when he was
crucified and they never die.
And so it's a kind of,
it's a,
it's a really powerful way of expressing everlasting life and the church being
the way to achieve that
briefly because I've got like two minutes left.
I've been chatting on about mountains,
too much stumbling stones.
Everyone loves a good all stumping stone.
You get them in circles,
you get them in rows.
Dot.
Most really good for stone rose.
And you also get single standing stones,
monoliths.
This monster is called the roadster and monolith.
It's in Yorkshire.
It's 7.6 meters high.
And surveys have shown that there's as much stone under the ground as there is
above,
which is pretty,
pretty cool.
Uh,
it's about 36 tons and it was probably dragged about 40 miles.
They're not really sure.
Um,
the reason that it's called [inaudible] and the whole village is called roadster
is because of this stone.
The original name was rude,
stone,
rude being,
uh,
an old English word for cross.
And the reason it's got this,
um,
led capping on the top is because at some point someone drilled a hole into the
top of the monolith and stuck her across in the top and it was used as a site
suffered gathering,
uh,
open worship,
so rude cross stone.
It's the name of the village,
the stone as named to the village.
The other weird thing is that it's about four meters away from the edge of the
parish church.
And so they respected the standing stone,
which is prehistoric and,
and it must have really edged around it and not knock it over while they were
constructing the church.
But it just indicates just how important,
how powerful sort of pre historic monuments are really.
Even now,
I like hugging,
hugging a standing stone is a thing of great joy for me.
Um,
the one on the right,
the Toblerones shape or the shark's tooth is on the outer Hebrides,
uh,
near Lewis.
It's near Callanish,
which is also really,
if you want a fun archeological trip,
I'd say go to the outer Hebrides or uh,
the Orkney islands,
the outer Hebrides.
You can fly in from Glasgow.
It's British Airways flight,
but you fly in and he landed on the beach at low tide on the island of bearer.
It's really fun when you're looking at standing stones.
Again,
you're trying to work out what's the significance,
why is it here and what does it all mean
and to work out whether it's prehistoric,
prehistoric standing stone.
First of all,
look for evidence of vertical weathering.
If it's been standing upright for three,
four,
maybe 5,000 years,
you'll see vertical erosion from where the rain has hit and run down.
If it's been raised more recently,
who might seem much smoother look for edges that appear to have kind of a
machine cut or bedding that suggests that it's more modern and then also look
out at the landscape is in conjunction.
Is it in some kind of connection with other monuments,
with other ancient or prehistoric features in the landscape or as,
as I sort of memory memorably.
Notice once a in a,
in a patch of whales can't go,
oh standing stone in that field and kind of trundled over to have a look at it
and then realize that there was actually a standing stone in the next field and
a standing stone in the next field and they all happen to be in the middle of
the fields.
And I realized that they were capital cattle rubbing stones for the cows to
scratch their bottoms on so that they wouldn't knock over gate posts.
And I thought,
oh well it is a standing stone but it's not,
not the standing stone.
And I was thinking it was going to be,
oh come on.
So I haven't,
I haven't touched on half of the stuff that's in the book.
You can entertain yourselves in your own leisure for pub names.
The reason we started off with medieval ale stakes and then ended up with
hanging pup signs that you'll sometimes see curling ivy or,
or kind of pretty metallic grapes laid over why you have red lines and black
boys and golden dare and Golden Hines,
uh,
y you can stare at a cottage and work out when it was constructed and how it's
been modified.
You can go to a pub in Suffolk and look for the Malian holes in the windows from
the original timbers when it was created as a medieval hall house.
You can wander through field systems like this and puzzle out how it was farmed
and what significance it has.
And the next time he walked past a dry stone wall,
have look at how it was constructed.
If you see a hole at the base,
then it might be used for sheep,
for the shepherds to push the cheap three.
And that's called a lung keyhole.
So there's really cool bits of Trivia in the book.
Um,
but hopefully my,
my aim is to share that passion,
to get outside and to explore and to discover for yourself and to stand in the
landscape and wonder what is it that I'm looking at and what does it tell me
about the story of the countryside around me.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible] we do have time for questions.
Hello.
So looking at excavating mounds and the like all their mounds that you think we
should not excavate simply so there's something for the next generation to
either explore.
That's a really good question.
Um,
archeology,
archeological excavation is inherently destructive because you dig into it and
then it's not there anymore.
And how of much he preserved.
There's stuff you're going to lose.
And some of the antiquarians back in the 18th and 19th centuries did a terrible
job and we're just looking for treasure.
They were effectively nighthawks,
but others were doing the utmost within the terms of,
of that era to be a scientific and rigorous as possible.
And so you get really beautiful patterning sketches.
But for a modern researcher,
that's not always that useful because you've lost all the organic remains.
You haven't got any samples that you can date.
You haven't got accurate records of what was where and how it was aligned and
associated with all the other things.
So I think it's,
it's,
it's inevitable that people in the future,
we'll look at the excavations that people are doing now and go,
what the heck were they doing?
They just have no idea how much material and how much information they were
losing.
So I think it's,
it's definitely advisable to not dig it all up just because we can,
well actually we can't because it's expensive and we haven't got any money.
Um,
but nonetheless,
money not withstanding,
it's,
it's valuable to leave stuff as aes.
And the growth in archaeology now is in non destructive techniques.
So gout,
ground penetrating radar imaging techniques from,
um,
from aerial images.
Um,
we can record artifacts much more carefully now with photogrammetry where you're
creating a kind of three d point clouds.
So you get absolute accuracy of information.
Dating techniques are coming on a pace as well.
But again,
if you want to radiocarbon date something,
you have to drill a hole into it and take out a sample.
So again,
you kind of have to choose what questions you want to answer.
Yeah.
So yeah,
leave some of it alone.
I think,
hi,
you talked about a couple of databases,
but I'm wondering on the whole how well recorded in database this stuff is.
Um,
and I guess I'm thinking from you know,
maps and apps sorts of point of view
there.
There isn't a really good app,
there isn't a really good app where you can say,
you know,
I kind of a Shazaam for archeology where you go,
what is that?
And it will go,
well,
your hair and this is that there are databases now that are being developed by
um,
uh,
historic Scotland by historic England,
um,
where they've brought together the historic environment records sites,
monuments records.
So these legal documents that schedule a monument as well as,
um,
surveys and the information,
that is attached to that they are accessible.
Most of them,
they're all free to access,
some of them are online.
The search functions aren't always great.
You might miss stuff.
But more and more they've got interactive maps.
So if you actually know about heritage gateway,
if you actually know about past escape,
you can go and find the stuff.
I think,
um,
the,
the problem is the general public don't necessarily know about it and it might
be slightly overwhelming to start off with cause you have to kind of do a bit of
wandering around.
So to work out what it is you're looking at and to kind of read through the
archeology,
ease to understand what is,
what is it that that's telling me this is a burial mound.
It's from the Bronze Age,
which is 2,400 BC to about 800 BC.
This is probably what's inside it.
These are the excavations or surveys that have been done now go and have a look
at it and find out these features and these features.
That would be fantastic.
It doesn't exist yet.
Any more questions?
Yeah,
I would guess that some of these features like the medieval tree management
would be common to sort of most of question Europe.
Um,
other things that are specific to Britain,
barrow shapes or anything like that?
Yeah,
yeah.
Boroughs,
we tend to share chambered,
barrows,
chamber teams and,
and long borrowers we tend to share with the Atlantic seaboard.
So the western coast,
so you get them in,
in western Spain and bit support school,
you get them across up three,
um,
the western coast of France and Germany as well.
Um,
the,
some of the medieval,
um,
land management systems are quite specific to Britain.
So we had great field systems that were very,
very elaborate and wealth,
um,
sort of managed in central and southern counties.
And actually when you see,
if any of you've ever seen those fields of like they look corrugated,
they've kind of got those ridge and furrow running along and it's normally
undergrad class and they're the evidence they had the remains of medieval
plowing that has been then turned over to grass.
And so those kinds of corrugations have been preserved.
Now the reason that there's such big wide ridge and furrow compared to like a
modern plow foro is because these fields were farmed community,
but different families have different strips.
So you'd have the strep and I'd have this strip.
And then in the next great field you'd have a couple of strips and I'd have a
few strips.
And so the land will be shared out between the whole community.
So it'll have some good stuff,
some bad stuff.
Um,
we'd worked together,
but we'd effectively plumber farm our own little bit,
but they weren't fields with hedges and fences like we imagine now they were
introduced in the,
some team 50s to 17,
18 is primarily as an act of parliament when they were in closing common land.
So that's a,
that's a kind of a mass change that we've got the remanence of these medieval
plowing systems.
But you've also got the parliamentary enclosure fields,
those lovely straight rectangular fields.
What we kind of imagine as the,
you know,
green and pleasant lands that we've all come become accustomed.
T is actually a function of a historical change that was massively traumatic for
a huge swathe of the population because they were booted out of land that they'd
lived on for ever.
Um,
and there was a huge depopulation of the countryside because these new private
landowners who would then fence off bits of land,
um,
would chuck the peasants off.
They put w we'll put sheep on top,
you know,
sheep required to shepherds,
whereas farming community,
hundreds more people.
So,
um,
yeah,
so that was a really good one.
Um,
in terms of like special British things,
crook frames are really good as well.
You know,
when you look at the end of an old cottage and you see the kind of the curved
beams that's been split from an Oak,
the same oak,
so you kind of get,
um,
normally,
you get a kind of a,
a mirror image that,
that quintessentially British as well and wield and whole houses,
if you want a trip to can't go and have a look for Wheeldon hall houses,
um,
which are really distinct and incredibly old.
They used to be like the stately homes of their day and now they look like kind
of slightly tumbling down cottages,
um,
with uh,
jettied first floor and you would have had a central area with a kind of an open
fire.
And the gallery for the servants and then,
uh,
kind of the top table up to the left.
The Deus.
Yeah.
So there's some,
there's some,
yeah,
really specific British things.
If you go up to Scotland actually get infield outfield farming systems,
that picture of Wasdale,
that's the lake districts,
but it's a similar system because obviously the,
the,
the fell side,
so,
uh,
quite,
quite hard to farm the quiet.
Um,
there's not that much return on them.
You can't cultivate them.
But the,
the valley floor is fertile ish if you clear the stones away and you work really
hard to nourish the soil over generation after generation.
And so the community hair,
before they broke it up into these tiny fields,
um,
would have an infield set of him fields which were heavily farmed and heavily
manured and then outfields that will be left fallow.
So they'd be used on rotation and then the fell signs would be common grazing.
And in the late district,
do you think of it as a very natural environment?
It's still grazed by Communists who get an allowance of sheep that they can put
on the fall side.
And that's why we've got the landscape we have today.
That's why you've got those green and pleasant valley's,
I'm those what nominally appeared to be kind of barren fell sides.
But the herd sheep that live up there a perfectly attuned because they've been
there since the vikings.
Probably the vikings probably brought Hardwick's
I've a question.
Well,
so when you go and explore the British landscape,
do you just think I want to learn something about this area and then you just go
there and have a look or do you study maps and look at what exactly do you want
to find and see?
It's um,
it's a bit of both really.
Sometimes you can do some fantastic landscape spotting in the pleasure and
comfort of your arm chair with a laptop.
You don't even need the paper maps anymore cause it everything's digitized.
And you can look on the heritage records and you can cross reference and some of
the old map,
um,
map systems have been digitized as well.
So you can cross compare modern ordnance,
survey maps,
Google maps,
Google earth is fantastic because you can kind of get a real sense of what,
what,
how things fit together in a way that you can't when you're on the ground
looking at human level.
Actually sometimes that aerial perspective just lets things fall into Fordham's
place.
And obviously with,
with smartphones and IPADS,
you can tablets,
you can do that in the field as well,
which is really fantastic.
Um,
there are,
there are certain places that I kind of thing I want to go and see that and I'm
going to go and explore.
Um,
and places that I like to go back to again.
So kill Martin Glenn up in Scotland is,
is a fantastic valley that's absolutely stuffed,
full of amazing.
Um,
prehistory history,
British rocker.
Oh,
that's another good one.
British walkup.
Really Weird,
quite subtle,
very,
very unique to Breslin.
Um,
but,
but then there's other places where you kind of just wander along and you see
stuff and because you've got half an idea of what your,
what you could be looking for,
what questions you could be asking.
When you stumble across something,
you can sort of do that wondering and wondering and start to try and puzzle out.
You might not come up with a black and white binary answer,
but for me,
the,
the joy is in the adventure of discovery,
not necessarily coming up with a kind of definitive answer and you can always go
back home and a check.
See what else other people have found out about the site.
Any more questions?
Yep.
Thanks.
Have most of the ancient sites in Briston pretty much been discovered and,
but pretty much using that book I will find things that are relevant.
Okay.
No,
there's still more to be discovered.
They found him a s a whole stone circle upon Dartmore not long ago.
And there's a,
it looks like there's a kind of a whole crescent of stone circles and it was
under the pizza.
There's loads of stuff under Pete.
There's loads of stuff under thick vegetation.
There's a chap up in Scotland who discovered over the course of I think 15
years,
he's found more than 2000 panels of British Waqar.
So these are carbon ring marks,
the engravings into either earth fast boulders or outcrops of stone and you get
like a little divot,
a cup,
and then you get a concentric circle.
The ring,
sometimes you get multiple rings,
sometimes you get a groove that joins the rings or a gutter that comes out from
the middle.
We don't really know why they were used.
They're constructed in the late nail ethic on the Bronze Age.
Maybe it was,
um,
they don't appear to be maps of any description,
but because they're um,
but they're not colored.
They may have been colored at at one point or another.
They may have been used to pour liquid onto oil or blood or milk to catch in
some way as a kind of reading of the future or perhaps as part of a ceremony.
Other people have said that actually it's the grindings of the stone that were
possibly the special thing.
And what we're seeing now is sort of the,
the cast off that just,
you know,
the empty shell of,
of what was left behind and they've taken the good stuff away,
but we consider it rock arts.
It seems significant and special in its own right,
but because it's normally quite low and it's quite subtle and sometimes you can
only see it if you get one of those like brilliant when today's,
you know,
really bright sunshine but the sun is low and so you get a real kind of cutting
across you,
you things stand out much more clearly.
So there's definitely more to be discovered and every now and then,
um,
things will be rewritten,
uh,
because of fines and discoveries that amateurs have made
time for.
One more question.
Yep.
Any other organization,
uh,
organize the archeological tours,
like say for amateurs,
not for professionals.
Works.
Yeah.
Uh,
there's a really good,
um,
organization called,
Oh God,
what are they called?
Dig Ventures.
Yeah.
Dig Ventures who,
um,
crowdfund archeology dates and they've got a virtual,
uh,
dig so that you can,
if you can't get to the site and be part of it,
then you can kind of follow along.
And they're really hot on sort of incorporating photogrammetry imaging
techniques so that it's as,
and then they open source,
publish all their findings.
So they're really good.
I'd definitely recommend them.
Um,
and I'm also going to be doing some archeological walks as well,
doing one in Ilkley.
If anyone fancies a trip to Yorkshire,
I'm on my website,
Mariano hearts.com.
Yeah.
It'll clean if you want to come and see some rock art march.
Ilkley it's nice.
It'll really fun.
Anyone been?
Yeah,
it's good,
isn't it?
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you very much,
Mariana.
Hot Tub.
Thank you.